it's great to welcome to the program
today Kara Ellerbe who is an associate
professor of political science and
Women's Studies at the University of
Delaware also author of the book no
shortcut to change an unlikely path to a
more gender equitable world Kara it's so
great to have you on of first and
foremost thanks for being here thank you
for having me so this is a very
interesting topic to me for a number of
different reasons one is that we've
talked for a long time about a debate
that while it's real it's often
mischaracterized about the difference
between prioritizing equality of outcome
versus equality of opportunity and I
think a lot of what you write about
relates to that but let's at least
briefly table that for a moment you
point out in the book that strategies of
trying to achieve at least gender
equality by sort of status quo plus
adding women have not worked out
particularly well in many cases can you
talk about that a little bit where can
we observe that and why do you think
that's not an effective strategy well I
think one of the priciest
examples are efforts to include more
women in governments kind of all over
the world they often use gender quotas
to do so while gender quotas seem to
help right the global average of the
number of women in national political
office is still only about 23 percent
that's less than 1/4 of the world's
governments that include women so
despite this being better than 10 years
ago
at this rate it could still take another
hundred years for most countries to have
gender parity just in terms of political
representation and why I mean at face
value
if you imagine okay we have a situation
of drastically uneven representation we
want to make it more equitable let's
make it a priority to get more women
involved why where is the disconnect
where it seems like it's identifying a
pretty clear problem and a sort of
path to a solution or to an improvement
why doesn't it work well it doesn't work
in part because there's often informal
dynamics so the formal rules may say yes
let's add more women but the informal
rules the gatekeeping of who gets to run
for office who has resources to run for
office these things that may not
systematically show up but we know
enough anecdotal evidence across the
across the world indicate that there's
other barriers they may be invisible
that still really keep women out of
positions of power yeah and some of them
I find are much more nuanced than maybe
the discussion allows for I mean I'll
sort of give one example you hear from
some contingence political contingents
in the United States now who say listen
this this just simply isn't the problem
women can now vote women can run for
office there's no practically
practically speaking any barriers to
having more women become elected
officials but then you look at a sort of
sort of second layer proxy to that and
you say well overwhelmingly the voting
public is choosing from candidates who
are disproportionately high-powered
attorneys CEOs of businesses and
whatever else right we could figure out
sort of what the top occupations are you
then need to sort of look at what is the
balance or imbalance within those sort
of agent careers that are most likely to
lead to becoming an elected official
would that be one example that's
actually a great example and we call it
a you know political pipeline right and
it's true for representation
there's pipelines also that push women
into different types of jobs within the
economy and there's also a pipeline in
seeking justice so I talk a lot about
these pipelines that that they're often
leaky so there's things along the way
where women sort of fall out of that
pipeline and and your example is it
starts with what kind of occupations
they have where they go to school what
sort of Rhys
sources they start out with right to
become a political representative is a
very elite position in and of itself so
it already is going to exclude most
women and most Americans what do you
think right now is from a sort of
structural standpoint maybe I mean I'm
glad to talk about the u.s. specifically
but we could talk more broadly or you
could talk about other areas where
you've done research when people who
don't believe that there are any sort of
structural inequalities remaining what
are the sort of best examples you can
point to as to what some of those
structural inequalities are there's this
common refrain now from a certain
political segment which says I'm as
against structure structural
inequalities when it comes to race
gender ethnicity whatever as much as the
next guy or gal but nobody's presented
me with a good example of what one would
be what would an example be um well I
think in terms of the economy right that
these offer great examples that many
occupations are still sex segregated
right so but there's there's no formal
rules that that women shouldn't go into
particular fields like construction or
mining or that men can't go into fields
like nursing or primary education but
but that there's forces at play that
sort of push people in particular ways
and that sort of invisible pushing is an
indication that that there's larger
processes going on besides just
individual decision making and and I
think that's the best way to capture
what it means to say something is
structural and then those jobs then are
paid very differently and that has to do
with how we value work which again is
also structural I don't know if that
sort of explains what you're trying to
get at or not I mean I guess it would be
great for for the audience's purposes to
now say okay we understand the idea of
what you're saying but what are some
specific examples I mean I know
generally you're talking about
construction nursing etc but one where
we could actually talk through the
mechanism that's taking place
so let's think in terms of we can go
back to political representation okay
who are our representatives well if you
look at the Senate we know that you have
to have a lot of resources to make it
there so what's the pool that we're
gonna we're going to draw from of people
who have those resources well it's not
primarily going to be the working class
so we certainly have examples of that to
kind of make it to those upper houses
you you have to have some kind of access
to wealth whether or not that came from
your family or generated through elite
education whatever you're also probably
going to be part of particular political
networks that put you in those positions
of power and those tend to favor was
tend to favor men right so we have
higher levels of women's representation
and at the state level but they don't
usually make the jump to national level
politics because those networks of of
who you need to help run don't operate
the same way so there's a lot of
evidence that men prefer other men to
build their social capital networks who
they do give favors for who they seek
out to be on their political teams and
that those networks then become what's
called very homeless social right so
they're kind of senior lead gen derd and
that that then disadvantages women
because they don't have access to those
you know to those same kind of networks
that actually garner political power but
it's often behind the scenes right we we
don't actually notice this and unless
you kind of dig into the data so let's
get now into now that we've kind of set
the stage there into an area where I
know that left and right disagree but
even within my primarily left-wing
audience there is some disagreement and
that gets to what I sort of mentioned at
the beginning this idea of equality of
outcome versus equality of opportunity I
think you've laid out very clearly here
many ways in which we don't truly have
equality of opportunity at this point in
time in many of these levels of
government and in other ways completely
Amon
with you now where my audience sometimes
will disagree is even if we had and
would hope to achieve at some point true
equality of opportunity for different
reasons we might not have equal total
equality of representation when it comes
to gender race whatever in our elected
officials let's focus just on the House
and Senate just to kind of narrow our
conversation we might get to a point
where we say we have equality of
opportunity and yet as a combination of
social reasoning job preference biases
who knows a whole bunch of different
reasons 60% of our elected officials
continue to be men and 40% continue to
be women or 5545 or whatever so my
question to you as someone who deals
with this academically is how can we
start to parse whether and what the
limits are to saying it's close enough
to proportional representation it
doesn't have to be exact how might we
explore that well in my book I really
advocate for changing what we what we
even call this in the first place for me
it's not you know putting more women
into office is not gender equality it's
women's inclusion and I think that in
and of itself is a worthwhile goal but
what I'm really interested in is that
can deal more with equality of
opportunity and I'm not sure that
debating you know the thresholds or when
you finally achieve that is necessarily
the point as is reframing what we even
think gender equality in the future can
mean right for me gender equality has
nothing to do with more women in
government because it's helping again a
kind of a small proportion of women its
impact is sort of it's important but is
it going to radically change the
relationship between men and women
between men and women of different races
and sexual orientations it covers over
all of that and sort of silent
is that yes so I think that's that's not
the goal
and so I I I've used the analogy that
when we think about international aid
for example that going and giving a
bunch of shoes to a place where people
don't have shoes it can sort of serve as
a band-aid and now people have shoes and
maybe they're better able to get to work
or whatever but it's doing nothing to
help that society build a shoe industry
eventually they'll still be unable to
buy shoes they'll still be unable to
make shoes and they'll be still
dependent on someone to give them shoes
and it's kind of sort of a neoliberal
critique a critique of neoliberalism in
that context is there a sort of analogy
to that in the critique you are issuing
of women's inclusion versus actually
furthering equality the analogy I use in
my book is you can if you think about
gender equality or women's inclusion and
the model that we have is sort of a
cookie recipe okay let's say chocolate
chip cookies I can add nuts to the
recipe without drastically altering that
it's still a cookie so you can add women
to institutions all you want it does
does nothing to guarantee that the
institutions that are exclusionary in
the first place are actually going to
change it all so it creates a kind of
unfair burden on women to do the work of
changing those institutions which could
get in the way of their kind of
individual leadership that's so the idea
being that forcing nuts into a whole
bunch of cookie recipes is not going to
change whether the cookie development
teams are even considering that nuts may
be something that you would want to have
in there precisely you're not asking
anyone else to necessarily do anything
different except that the women's
presence is supposed to capture that
absolutely fascinating of this idea is
elaborated a lot more in Kara's book no
shortcut to change an unlikely path to a
more gender equitable world kara Ellerbe
associate professor at the University
City of Delaware really a pleasure
having you on and I appreciate it so
much thank you for having me